now to Turkey in Syria where hope is
fading fast to find survivors days after
the catastrophic earthquake rocked the
region the death toll has crossed 24 000
but there are still remarkable rescues
happening just today a team pulled five
members from a single family who were
trapped for 129 hours that's more than
five days but conditions are growing
more dangerous for Rescuers with every
passing moment in the southernmost
province of turkey debris fell onto a
rescue member of a team as he tried to
reach trapped survivors he was later
rescued from underneath the rubble by
his teammates who had escaped the Fallen
debris Chris livesay is in the disaster
Zone with Rescuers who are working
around the clock
the sun has set on the fifth day since
the earthquake hope is beginning to slip
through the Ragged fingers they've been
digging with Rescuers Are Climbing
inside all they've sliced and proof of
this apartment building that's come
crashing down and it's one of several
scenes all in the span of one city block
it's one of the most apocalyptic things
we've seen
to mention that we're smelling and
tasting because the air is thick with
dust and with smoke although similar
scenes like this are being played out
all across the devastated area
in turkey's Southeastern city of adiaman
they now live among the rubble every one
of them with relatives inside battling
both the grief and the cold
look at us says epec I don't have any
shoes I don't have any water to wash my
hands we have nothing there are more
dead people here than alive this city is
a cemetery successful rescues do still
happen 15 year old ifair sandwiched
between slabs of concrete for 99 hours
she tells her saviors she'd like some
ice cream
double chocolate or white chocolate he
says
before pulling her limp body to safety
and baby Aya which means miracle in
Arabic born amidst the rubble in Syria
thousands from around the world have
offered to adopt her but she'll live
with an uncle but on this block in
adiaman there have been no rescued
children today
Instead The Weeping daughter and sister
of gulsaroon
it was her birthday last Saturday two
days before she went missing beneath the
debris her sister epec just had to bury
their mother and father if they started
rescues one or two days sooner perhaps
they'd be alive she says and my sister
would be safe do you have any hope left
that your sister might still be alive
for CBS Saturday morning Chris live say
a diamond turkey